der neue irre von teheran blues richter
das sind die begriffe mit denen man den
neuen iranischen präsidenten beschreiben
kann beschreiben sollte ibraimi sie hat
die wahl zum neuen iranischen
präsidenten gewonnen
bei seiner ersten pressekonferenz hatte
schon direkt klar gemacht er steht für
einen sehr harten kurs möchte
beispielsweise us präsidenten joe biden
nicht treffen
die amerikaner sollen die sanktionen
gegen den iran aufgeben
der iran ist nicht bereit über seine
raketentechnologie und regionale politik
zu verhandeln
ihnen diesen mann genauer erklären und
wen handelt sich da ich habe gesagt der
neue irre von teheran und ehrlich gesagt
das wird ihre es fast ein bisschen
verharmlosend wenn man realisiert wie
viel blut an den händen von ibm ra ii
sie wirklich klebt er ist als richter
verantwortlich für die hinrichtung für
den tod von tausenden oppositionellen
das muss man erst mal so auf sich wirken
lassen er steht dafür eben bis heute auf
der sanktionsliste der usa und der eu
die der iran das ist natürlich keine
demokratie iran ist ein land das von den
mullahs von den ayatollahs gesteuert und
gelenkt wird und dort kommt man
natürlich nur auf die wahlliste wenn man
ein mann von diesen von diesen
staatsführern ist man auf deren seite
steht und dazu gehört eben auch über
easy er steht für diesen iran den iran
der verschleierten frauen wo frauen zu
menschen zweiter klasse gemacht werden
bis zur unkenntlichkeit eigentlich
verschleiert im alltag drangsaliert und
diese beiden bilder haben wir ausgesucht
weil sie so schön für die beiden seiten
des iran stehen auch so dramatisch links
haben wir iranische alltagsleben anfang
der 70er jahre junge frauen an der uni
teheran in bunten kleidern ja sie
genießen das normale leben und das recht
so ist eben heute teilweise der alltag
an der uni teheran weil man eben an der
staatsspitze männer hat wie ibm ra sie
die wollen das so im iran gelebt wird
das ist ihre welt und ihr modell
wir schauen weiter auf diese situation
dort in dem land und sehen die opfer von
diesen neuen staatspräsidenten denn ende
der 80er jahre ich habe es gesagt hat er
also als richter gearbeitet und hat dort
zehntausende oppositionelle verurteilt
das waren menschen die eben nicht
akzeptieren wollten dass sich der iran
so entwickelt hat wie er sich entwickelt
hat und dafür sind todesurteile gefällt
worden grausame hinrichtung hat
stattgefunden da sind 56 menschen
nebeneinander aufgehängt worden
an stricken die haben dann noch zehn 15
minuten um ihr leben gekämpft und sind
am ende
qualvoll erstickt und die die menschen
die diesen albtraum damals überlebt
haben die in den foltergefängnissen
waren die haben
jeder hat was sie da erlebt haben wie
zum beispiel hier die frau war idee gut
da sie sie war eine frau die schwanger
im achten monat von den mullahs
verhaftet worden ist wie in so eine
folter kamera war kam und dann
hochschwanger jeden tag geschlagen und
geprügelt wurde
und der richter der diese folterverhöre
überwacht und kontrolliert hat das ist
der heutige staatspräsident dass iran
das ist der mann der damals da war und
sich das angehört hat und diese frau sie
hat amnesty international geschildert
was sie erlebt hat sie hat nämlich ihren
sohn zur welt gebracht und erzählt
amnesty international
mein sohn war 38 tage alt als sie ihn
nahmen und auf den boden warfen sie
nahmen ihn und schlugen ihm auf den
rücken und die ganze zeit stand die sie
dort und schaute zu das ist der mann der
den iran jetzt lenkt das ist der mann
der an der spitze des landes steht und
das ist die realität im iran bis zum
heutigen tag wir sehen hier heizungen
auf öffentlichen plätzen als ein jahr
gängiges eine gängige methode menschen
zu bestrafen
der junge mann der hier an den baum auf
einem platz gekettet und gebunden wurde
was hat er getan er ist 15 16 jahre alte
hat alkohol getrunken
und dafür wird er hier von der
religionspolizei ausgepeitscht mit 80
peitschenhieben das ist die strafe ein
bild wie wir sie aus dem sogenannten
dieses kalifat vielleicht kannten aber
das sind situationen die die menschen im
iran bis zum heutigen tag erdulden und
erleiden müssen wir haben hier
zusammengefasst was sind zu strafen für
die man ausgepeitscht werden kann zum
beispiel wenn man homosexuell ist oder
wenn man sich kritisch mit der religion
auseinander setzt wenn man drogen oder
eben alkohol trinkt oder wenn man eben
sagt ich möchte mit dieser staatsführung
nichts zu tun haben wenn man all das
sieht und hört dann können einem die
iraner im iran eigentlich nur leid tun
und vor allem wünscht man sich so sehr
für sie dass es ihnen irgendwann gelingt
sich von diesem staat terror diese
mullahs zu befreien und wieder ein
freies heute zu werden ja bei uns im
studio ist jetzt ein mann der weiß wie
es sich anfühlt wenn die eigene familie
davon betroffen ist unser kollege
niemand sie vielen dank dass du heute
hier bist denn dein vater wurde
tatsächlich von risi zum tode
urteilt er hat ihn also auf dem gewissen
was damals passiert wie ist es dazu
gekommen
mein vater war genau wie viele andere
iraner am anfang die iranische
revolution islamische revolution sehr
aktiv gewesen und wurde 1988 wo ich zwei
jahre alt war meine mutter neunten monat
schwanger war hingerichtet was genau wie
muss man sich das vorstellen wie läuft
das ab gibt es da überhaupt einen
prozess von fair möchte ich da gar nicht
sprechen wie lief das damals unter
diesem blut rechter mein vater war knapp
40 tage im gefängnis später haben wir
mitgekriegt mitbekommen dass sogenannte
faire prozesse im islamischen staat zwei
maximal fünf minuten dauern
ohne anwaltliche vertretung dürfte sich
auch nicht mehr verteidigen und wurde zu
tode verurteilt kannst ja mal sagen was
ist ihnen damals überhaupt vorgeworfen
worden was war der grund warum ihm
dieser schau prozess gemacht wurde
er war genau wie viele andere iraner
damals friedlich auf eine demo gewesen
und gegen die islamische staat
demonstriert demonstriert seine meinung
geäußert und gesagt verhaftet und wenige
tage auch hingerichtet wir sehen hier
hinter dir deinen vater und deine mutter
sag uns einmal was hat der der tod die
ermordung seines papas was hat das mit
mit eurer familie gemacht
das ist schwer zu beschreiben
meine schwester konnte dürfte ihrer
seite unserer eigenen vater nicht
kennenlernen
wir sind im iran mit großer angst gewalt
aufgewachsen
wir haben wir leiden immer darunter
meine mutter ist seit knapp 15 jahren in
deutschland wir leiden immer darunter
sie wenn wir sie besuchen wollen dann
müssen wir vorher voran kundigen weil
sie angst hat dass die revolutionsgarde
wieder vor ihrer tür steht
was was forderst du jetzt von
europäischen vereinen von deutschen
politikern die jetzt hoch wie sie also
tatsächlich präsident gewordene so viel
macht jetzt in dem land hat sie ist
mitverantwortlich für
massenhinrichtungen im iran für
menschenrechtsverletzungen
gestern eine pressekonferenz er hat
deutlich seinen taten verteidigt er hat
keine rolle erklärt er ist eigentlich
nicht für die internationale bühne
gedacht er muss vor eine internationale
gericht gestellt werden und verurteilt
werden
lieber maximilian alle unsere
demokratische länder sprechen über
menschenrechte rechte für frauen rechte
für homosexuelle gegen antisemitismus es
ist unsere aufgabe als westliche länder
endlich klar zu stellen auf welche seite
wir stehen
wir können nicht mit einer regierung die
für massenhinrichtungen ist frauen in
gefängnissen vergewaltigt homosexuell
und jugendliche hingerichtet und
holocaust leugnet wie dürfen mit so
einer regionen nicht verhandeln ge
iraner wir fordern eine einreise stopp
für totes richter reicht der darf nicht
zu uns kommen
und ja ich habe noch eine frage du hast
gerade gesagt deine mama die hat bis
heute eigentlich angst ihr müsst euch
vorher ankündigen
jetzt weiß man dass iranische agenten in
europa aktiv sind dass die
oppositionelle am morgen dass die
sprengstoffanschläge geplant ist das was
was euch beschäftigt ist das was bevor
man sorge hat dass das regime einen
hieraus spitze das informationen
gesammelt werden selbstverständlich jede
politische aktivitäten im ausland machen
mussten wir mit angst machen das muss
man sagen dieses dieses regierung hat
mehrere anschläge in europa ausgeübt
miconos in berlin
im februar wurde ein iranischer diplomat
zu 20 jahre haft verurteilt weil er ein
anschlag in europa ausüben wollte wir
mussten achten wir leben immer noch mit
angst aber wir lassen uns nicht
einschüchtern
immerhin vielen dank dass du bei uns
bist und vor allem danke dass du das so
persönlich heute mit uns bringt halter
ein dankeschön danke dafür
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren